Hello everyone! I'm Dr. Colleen Carnell
and with me today is Michelle Coursey,
and we're going to be answering your
questions about ancient Egyptian
makeup and cosmetics here on the Vintage
Egyptologist Youtube. And earlier today we
filmed an incredible makeup tutorial that
you can check out at My Vintage Love blog,
yes on @myvintageloveblog on instagram
or Myvintagelove here on youtube,
and it was really fun we did a daytime 20s
look and then transitioned it to a flapper vamp
evening look it was really wonderful because,
because Colleen has a perfect 20s face, as you
know. Thank you so much! I don't think I can hear
that enough times. I know right never gets old
So what I want to start with looking through
the hundreds of questions that we received
for this episode is with an object, and this
is a vanity set in the Metropolitan Museum of
Art. It is from 1800 roughly BCE meaning that
it is 3,800 years old, and it looks just like
a modern vanity set. Doesn't it? It really does.
I would 100 percent put this on my vanity - it's
tiny and compact, which makes me think that we
would appreciate it now, and they would have
appreciated it in the 20s because there
was a lot of itty bitty tiny compacts,
and it was just large enough to actually have
a hand mirror, and of course you can't do your
makeup without a mirror. You definitely need a
mirror here to do your makeup. It's fascinating
and we know that the surfaces would have been
polished. There's a fabulous example also in
the Metropolitan Museum of Art where the handle
is gold and the mirror surface is silver, so if
you get to the same level in the case you can see
your face reflected in this mirror. That's amazing
and it would have been a relatively small mirror
to fit in the in the compact face yeah the uh
that's pretty you know you can definitely see
your face in that yes yeah that's that's really
amazing yeah and so the less expensive
models would have had polished bronze
but the queen who actually owned the gold and
silver mirror in the metropolitan museum of art
obviously coming from the absolute upper echelons
of society and how how much makeup was worn by all
classes versus just the upper classes in royalty
was it very much the prominence of of that world
or was everyone wearing it a makeup of some kind
that's actually a really really great question
and it's hard to say because of our source
material so most of the times when we see
depictions of farmers of people working out in
the fields making wine all of these day-to-day
activities that we see herdsmen for example in
old kingdom middle kingdom and new kingdom tombs
that's an elite context that's a wealthy tomb
owner depicting people and obviously they want
to show themselves an absolute finery and we know
that during festivals and ceremonies most people
probably aspired to have a full face of makeup
now the extent to which that happened on an
everyday basis like i said it's very hard
to gauge because of our source material
so in ancient egypt was there makeup for special
occasions like weddings and things like that
so it's really interesting that the annual
festivals that we know were really important
in communities like Thebes, modern day Luxor, as
well as all throughout Egypt each city had its own
festivals and then there seemed to have
been national festivals like the new years
which would have happened really end of july
beginning of august where everyone partook of
these massive ceremonies and drinking as well
as wearing your finest clothing and makeup
and wigs would have been a part of that but
it's also really interesting looking at the
evidence from ancient egypt that we don't have any
descriptions of wedding ceremonies oh interesting
yeah you would think wow with a society so focused
on religion and ritual yes weddings and marriage
yes were predominantly an economic affair in
terms of a bringing together of two estates
at the same time they were affairs of love and
so if you fell out of love with the person that
you had married you could divorce and remarry and
there wasn't these elaborate religious rituals or
annulments that would be needed to make those
arrangements instead you would have an economic
renegotiation and we have that really well
attested in the ancient papyri so we've gotten a
little bit away from makeup interesting i just
think that's we think about makeup for these
life-changing events and they certainly had that
yeah but not in exactly the same way okay can you
talk more about wigs and how that was used was it
a ceremonial purely ceremonial was it an everyday
thing um would men and women wear them what's
tell me tell me more about wigs in engineering
so like makeup wigs were intended for both men and
women okay and like makeup wigs were intended to
enhance your appearance but just how lipstick is
not going to conceal your natural lip a wig did
not entirely conceal the existence of your hair
and if you look closely particularly there's this
famous statue of a woman named Nofret and
her husband Rahotep and they are perfectly
absolutely perfectly preserved down to the inlaid
rock crystal in their eyes so that when you look
at these statues it looks as if they're looking at
you wow and in both cases they are wearing makeup
which is really nice interesting to see yeah and
they're both uh the woman is wearing a wig he is
not he's wearing close cropped hair but we know
that in other contexts Rahotep just like Nofret
would have worn wigs but what i love
about that statue is that she's wearing this very
large wig and typically they went larger on the
hairstyles wigs were made out of human hair and
often these very very elaborate the higher
they are the closer to god kind of thought
i had to see this okay and you can see her natural
hair right below the wig oh okay this is a statue
obviously if they didn't want her natural hair
visible they would have changed that yeah they
didn't have to include that but very often they
do so they're acknowledging okay this is her real
hair it was probably pretty close cropped which
is what would have been comfortable in the heat
of ancient egypt but at the same time then you put
on that wig so wigs like makeup were especially
appropriate to these festival occasions a time
when the statues of the gods would come out from
the temples typically carried in portable barks
portable boats held on the shoulders of priests
and this would be a festival in which the entire
population could participate so unlike the sacred
space of a temple where the average person
could only go so far and certainly was not
part of the day-to-day ritual that was for priests
although and i'm getting way way off the topic of
makeup although i'll talk about the whether priests
wore makeup in just a moment but it's interesting
that not all priests in ancient Egypt were
professional priests oh so even though we talk
about priests doing certain things this is not a
separate class which i think is really it can be
in the new kingdom okay but a lot of times people
who were high priests even might have earlier in
their career been in the military been in the
civil service so it's not as if you have priests
and then the rest of the egyptian population okay
during the middle kingdom for example at a time
when the man who owned that amazing vanity
set yeah that would have been a time where
a lot of people working in the temple would
have been rotating throughout the year so you
would really have a sense of what went on within
a temple complex interesting wow i always thought
priests were just a class entirely into themselves
you know almost from birth they were brought up as
priests but i you're the professional i don't know
that's why it's one of those things where the more
listen do you speak and john speak the more i
realize the less i know it's my next phase of
knowledge well thank you but also i feel like it's
really important to address these topics because
there's so many misconceptions about how ancient
egyptian society functioned and i think that
knowledge of marriage and priests and things
that we might associate very strongly with egypt
that weren't true at all and i think as a great
tie-in actually to our makeup tutorial earlier is
it's all about the sources oh yeah so you have to
go back and read the hieroglyphic sources and say
okay is this a professional priest or is this
someone who's rotating and we can see that in
the titles just like if you want to research a
1920s makeup look you don't simply google 1920s
makeup look you go back to the advertisements
and the movies yes and the photos the photos
yes and that's if there's nothing else you take
away from any of our videos always go back to
the original sources know what your sources
are um you know looking watching the 1960-61
Elizabeth Taylor Cleopatra is not going to tell
you what you need to know about ancient Egypt
um go read one of their lovely books or you
know do do look at the source material and
you know watch watch an actual claribo film
and instead of instead of you know watching
a youtube makeup tutorial on 1920s makeup um
if you really want to see what they were doing
that's that's definitely the best message i
can send about just history in general the
source material is always the best place to start
with the exception of the 20s makeup tutorials
and i'm really glad you mentioned cleopatra
because there were so many questions about
cleopatra in fact so many that she
really deserves her own episode yeah
so for those of you who really want to know about
cleopatra in detail you will have to wait but i do
want to address the changeover between pharaonic
egypt and the greco-roman period and since you
brought up elizabeth taylor and cleopatra
this really important point that one of the
queens of egypt that probably very rarely
wore ancient egyptian clothing and makeup
was cleopatra because she was greek is that
correct exactly cleopatra the seventh the famous
cleopatra is the last in the very long line
of kings that begins with ptolemy the first
one of the generals of alexander the great
who takes over egypt in 332 bce now we do not
know exactly what cleopatra would
have worn in her day-to-day life
but chances are both her clothing and her makeup
would have been in hellenistic greek style yes
now when she was in temples performing rituals for
example if you traveled to the temple of Dendera
in Upper Egypt dedicated to the goddess Hathor
who we'll be talking about in more detail that
is where we have the most famous relief carvings
of cleopatra vii in fact those are the well-known
relief carvings in upper egypt in full egyptian
style and she's dressed identically to someone
from over a thousand years earlier oh amazing
but some small variations i should actually say
so when she went to perform these rituals as an
egyptian queen then she might have worn the wig
then she might have applied the makeup
then she might have worn the clothes
but how you see in the movie where she
has and i don't think any ancient egyptian
ever wore eyeliner that quite looks like
that because if we look at the ideal
of makeup we think of the boss of nefertiti and
that's very subtle yeah i mean she just has the
ringed around the eye but then pulled out slightly
that's pretty much it right in terms of eyeliner
yes very very very subtle and even her her lip
color is very subtle her blush is subtle so
quite the opposite from what we see in movies
like yes cleopatra yes but i love how that that
idea kind of came together and i just i just
really wonder like what what source material was
elizabeth taylor looking at and the makeup artist
for that to say yes that's that's the look we're
gonna go for because i think she did actually a
lot of her own makeup in that movie which is also
is my understanding i should probably look
more into that but i i believe she did
quite a bit of her own makeup and then she would
go out with richard burton on the town and leave
some of the makeup on and get photographed by the
paparazzi and that's how kind of how it became
such a big fed into the 60s eyeliner extravaganza
that was happening during the 60s um all the crazy
eye makeup so it's you know feeding in into
each other which is just fascinating i think
and that's that's such a good point right that
movie makeup isn't so much about the historical
time period yeah as it is about when the movie's
being made exactly and i have exactly as well
claudette colbert's look oh yeah and her cleopatra
and the height of 1930s bias cut oh yeah style
the brow you know the plucked out drawn on brow
it's it's so fascinating to watch that you know
yeah there's probably cleopatra movie in every
decade i assume colbert elizabeth taylor
who else i'm having i'm drawing a blank but
i'm i'm i can almost bet money that in the 40s
caesar and cleopatra yes oh yes and she's oh she's
so beautiful um but yeah also it's you know every
every movie made is told through the lens that
it's filmed in and i feel like in the last 20
years like we've certainly i think they try to be
more realistic but we're still through the lens of
the 2010s and it's it's just the way it's always
going to be so but that is really interesting and
back to what we're seeing before source material
um is is always the place you want to you want to
start and it's always fascinating to see the lens
any movie at any thing through the lens it was
filmed in and you can take that as inspiration but
you know source material is king absolutely yeah
talk to me a little bit about facial hair on
men fake real all that good stuff i think this
is another great myth yeah that exists in the
modern world about ancient egypt is that kings
wore these goatees right that's kind of the image
we have in our mind from the statuary right but if
you go back to king Djoser roughly 2650 bce he's
the guy buried in the step pyramid okay so yeah we
went there exactly amazing site Saqqara one of my
favorite sites in egypt and there was a statue
in a chamber just to the north of the actual
step pyramid actually joins uh the step pyramid
and in that chamber was a statue of king Djoser
and when it was cleaned it was realized that
he had a mustache oh that was unusual i would
i would think but it actually isn't a lot of
it is that our source material we tend to
think about images but if you start looking
for mustaches they're surprisingly common really
particularly in the old kingdom so Rahotep
that we were just talking about and his wife know
fred yeah he has really a douglas fairbanks junior
style 1930s movie star mustache i love that
okay what were they using to shave back then
they had razors really there are so many razors
known from ancient egypt and my favorite are
razors so they're made out of copper or bronze
they would have obviously been sharpened yeah
and some of them even had a combination tweezer so
that you had you could use your tweezer and then
use your razor wow and during the middle
kingdom so the time of that vanity set
both mustaches and beards were pretty common the
mummy masks in the middle kingdom could actually
show combination of beard goatees mustaches
which is neat and even if we look at those
royal depictions of the king wearing the goatee
if you look carefully most of the statues show a
strap that connected yeah i was gonna ask about
that beard okay that's not the pharaoh's
beard that's a false beard that's put on for
ritual activity okay yeah that's what i that
was my vague understanding of it yeah strictly
ritual thing to put on during ritual um to
appease the gods like what was the to look like
a god like what was the thought of the dress
that you were supposed to have so it was part of
the pharaoh of the king's ceremonial attire okay
in the early part of Hatshepsut's reign where
she's showing herself as a woman wearing a dress
she does not wear the false beard okay
and it is only when she shows herself
fully male that she then wears the beard
okay so it's not as if she and we don't know
just like when we were talking about cleopatra
we can't be certain what she actually wore
day to day right but we can assume
what she wore for the temple rituals
we actually don't know what Hatshepsut as a
female king which was a very unusual occurrence
even in ancient egypt what she would have
worn.  It's possible she would have worn
a dress with a kilt tied over it and then maybe
did put on the false beard it's really difficult
to say okay and the false beard would have
been only something pharaohs would have worn
period it wasn't that like a normal everyday
thing as far as we can tell okay yes now whether
some people decided to wear it who knows as far
as we have it depicted it is a strictly royal
accoutrement okay now there's also a type of
beard that is for the gods and that tends to
be longer and curved at the end okay and that
is something that marks a god like osiris
the king can then have that beard when he is
osiris in the afterlife so for example there
are some statues of Hatshepsut in the guise
of osiris and she has that beard okay interesting
wow um i think the cosmetic that people associate
with ancient egypt the most is kohl and talk to
me about that what was it used for what was it
made out of was everyone wearing it yeah kohl
for the ancient egyptians was galena this black
colored eye paint which they also had green or
likely malachite and we know from tactual evidence
particularly this letter that only the highest
quality galena was worthy of the pharaoh and if
it did not achieve a certain level of quality
it could be sent back and it's this amazing
document where the high priest is taking this
man to task for not sending high quality enough
galena for pharaoh's eye paint did they have it
was basically just black and green do they have
any blue or anything like that or was it just
inspired it's interesting we
know that the egyptians used both turquoise and
lapis lazuli for jewelry so it is possible that
either one could have been used in rare cases okay
for makeup application but typically when we have
lists of makeup it's the "mesdemet" the galena
or the kohl and it's the "wadjet" which is the
green the malachite okay interesting that would
have been i guess i'm just geeking out about the
makeup artist i like to know about the intensity
of color would have been in a very intense green
for the would have yeah it would
have been more of a subtle green
i wish we knew yeah i mean because what we have
is we have the depictions of them right so it's
it would be amazing to go back in time and see
what the makeup actually looked like that i
think that the bust of nefertiti shows in a
pretty accurate way a makeup a full makeup look
from the 18th dynasty right normally other
statuary has a stylized representation
so did they really have eyeliner did they
really have coal that was that strong yeah
we can't say yeah because that's what they
chose to commemorate in their art and a final
question that i wanted to tackle was permanent
skin enhancement oh which is tattooing yeah
the oldest figural tattoos anywhere in the
world are on an ancient egyptian natural mummy
oh wow around on the face it's on the shoulder
okay yeah it's on the shoulder so this is body
adornment in general but no no no tattooed makeup as
far as we can tell although there is a very large
udjat eye that's on one woman's neck oh wow
and we know of these tattoos because they
survive on the skin of mummies oh wow that's
really interesting so they actually had a full
jet eye on her neck yes wow and we
know how they were doing that like the
needles just over and over again in the skin
with ink one assumes which charcoal with
charcoal seems to be holy cow that must have
been and that wasn't jewelry i mean she has
quite a number of tattoos this female mummy and
this is a fairly recent discovery because of new
photography techniques being able to capture the
tattoos on mummies so we've known for a long time
that mummies could have tattoos because you can
see them visually very clearly just with the naked
eye but with infrared photography we're starting
to capture more and more of those tattoo images
oh wow because they're obviously not unwrapping
the mummy they can just photograph it through
infrared photography these are bodies that are
already unwrapped but then photographing the skin
using the infrared spectrum wow you can pull
that out that's very cool i have no idea so that
that you're saying that is the earliest known
tattoos basically the earliest figural tattoos
that we can definitively trace and date are
from the nile valley okay wow learning so much
and did you want to talk about
skin care in ancient egypt as well
so the egyptians had quite a lot of oils and
fats that they would have used for skin care
now we don't know anything chemically about
sunblock we do have depictions from the early
middle kingdom from the brain of manchester ii
of a woman beneath a parasol oh so that was one
option for uh skin care in ancient egypt in terms
of blocking out the sun physically yeah which is
great 1920s uh connection obviously and in
other cases it was probably a whole range
of very very expensive scented onions for the
higher classes and then probably pretty simple
animal fat used as a moisturizer for a
much larger segment of the population
okay i just i just don't know how comfortable
that was i can just imagine very hot climate
and then putting animal fat on yourself i just
buy small questions well okay small quantities
and can obviously be mixed yeah oh so more like
a moisturizer kind of that's how i that's how i'm
imagining okay i just think i hear your animal fat
i'm like crisco no no no no as a tiny ingredient
as a binder exactly as opposed to something like
an oil that was very expensive to produce okay
and something i've always heard and you tell
me if this is completely wrong is um of the
putting the perfumed combs of wax on their head
and it would melt and is that did that happen
okay i'm so glad you mentioned that i did not
want to end this before we discussed perfumed
wax coats excellent and what is exciting about
this is one was actually found on a mummified
body oh wow in middle east so they were buried
with them occasionally at least one person was
wow so this was a debate up until this moment
is are those perfumed or scented wax cones
an artistic license or is this something
that people did particularly during festivals
during parties so not a wedding party but
a funerary banquet the new year's festival
these times when people would come together
and dine and feast and drink both beer and wine
is that you would put one of these
scented cones on your on top of your wig
and as the night wore on it would melt
and then you would have this nice scent
oh wow emanating from your wig and that
enhanced the festival atmosphere because myrrh
incense in ancient egyptian is symmetry
which literally means to make divine
so by putting on that nice scent you are enhancing
the entire experience because to burn incense in
the temple is to literally make the god manifest
wow that's interesting i think that i wonder if
their concept of smell was different than ours
was because i think of a bunch of bodies being
in a warm room and this warm temperature with
the wax and the just everything happening and i
wonder what to our modern day you know nose would
that what would that smell like what would it be
like to be in that room with all of those scents
going on would be fascinating and everyone was
sniffing lotuses oh my gosh there would have been
a lot of smell a lot of flowers perfumed onions
so it was potentially a very rich yes sensory
environment yes and then the makeup and everything
just the wigs and everything happening i can only
only imagine what it was like wow well thank you
so much for joining me michelle thank you for
having me it was wonderful i learned so much
there are so many questions left to answer so as
john and i always say in our youtube videos here
it's going to be another episode so there's an
entire episode in cleopatra an entire episode on
the religious significance i said we were going
to get to hawthorne sadly we did not quite get
to her but the goddess who is the patroness of
makeup and cosmetics precisely because she is
the goddess who personifies the eye of the sun but
to really get into that concept we need a lot more
of the background of her myth and how painting
your eye was also an act of devotion and ritual
i like that idea a lot so don't forget to
subscribe here on vintage egyptologist and then
see the full 1920s makeup tutorial at my vintage
love blog and we'll see you in a future video